extensive tactical voting tactical
voting is always a hot topic when it
comes to election time
especially in this election because of
the b word how do you feel voting ukip
i feel sad about doing that but i'll do
anything to stop the tourism
but what is it and why do people do it
this is tactical voting
in three minutes sometimes people talk
about tactical voting as though it's a
sort of lower form of democracy
tactical voting is pretty much what it
says on the tin you use your vote
in a tactical way to increase the chance
of getting a result you like
it first hit the headlines in the 1997
election
and it exists because of our electoral
system which is called first past the
post
it's pretty simple the party with the
most votes in each constituency
wins but that can result in people
feeling like their vote doesn't really
matter
especially in seats where parties tend
to win comfortably
that's where tactical voting comes in
you could vote swap
this is where you agree to vote for a
party on someone else's behalf
and they'll vote for your party in their
constituency this is a way of hacking
the election
it works like this imagine you're a
brexit party supporter
your constituency is a safe labor seat
but if everyone who didn't support
labour voted for the conservatives
labour might not win in another
constituency
the brexit party has a shot at winning
and needs all of the votes they can get
so in this scenario you could vote swap
with a conservative party supporter
in that other constituency to help both
of your preferred mps win
there are even legal vote swapping
websites or match you up with other
voters
it only becomes illegal if coercion is
involved
the whole system works on trust you're
trusting that stranger to keep their
word
and vote for the party you want just as
they're trusting that you'll do the same
another type of tactical voting is
voting for the least worst
option let's imagine you're a green
party supporter but you don't mind the
liberal democrats
if you know that the lib dems have a
better chance of winning in your
constituency
you might vote for them instead of the
green party
that way even though your favorite
hasn't been elected you're still
quite like your mp this way of tactical
voting is more coordinated than ever
before
because of you guessed it brexit
instead of voting for parties some
people are saying they will tactically
vote for policies
most notably a second referendum
some people might think that tactical
voting is a fairly cynical way of taking
part in an election
but more people than ever say they've
done it and it could become an
even bigger feature in future elections
and that's tactical voting
in three minutes